I
CONTROL ITS COUNTRY'S > WEOMANDT
WORLD LEAD AND NEWETLS
D
DEAD.EST GAM FKIDNAPPED IN MST
THE TWO OTHERSHOUGH ONE IS SEVEL
FOR MEDICAL TREATMENT ANE TWO HH
OBSERVATION.
TIGNIP OFROO MEXICO SAT
T DIL
PROCEDURE DONE A
THEOMAS
INTO, FRIENDS EV
THATOT LOST ANS
ABDUCTED.
THE STE DEPAWHITE
HOUSE, AND S DT SAI
TH.
U.S. OFFICIAPREVIOD CNVEEXICAN
RTMISTOOK E
AMDR
SMUGGLERRES STARTS US OFF FROM
VETH
VICTIMRVIVORS.r: TWO OFO
ST AANS ARE BACK IN THE UNITED
EA TEXASIN
KIDNO.
AFTEWH. OFFICIAL TELLS
F EN
MB PFOUND DER UND VERELY IIN T A
ZISHINGTON McGEE ANDRIMSUR
WOODWORD WERE  CROSSED THEDE
MEXICON FRID F McGO TAIN ATHEY H
NORTH CANA TND GOT LOS
LAT
ED, TH
CNN.Y WEREBL LTHE  VIDEOAFTERMA
AND  TO VAOUS
DE CAPTUREICIALS.
THMEXICAN PRESIDEWS CONFERENCE
AP F HAITI DUGGLERS.STATE DEPAR
T LEVEFO WARNI NOT TABDUCTED THA
HEAVY CRIME AND IN THE REGION.
>> THERE ARE OSS OVER THARDER FT
CAINTMENTS.
>> ATTACKS ON U.S. CITIZENE
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> McGEE AND WIL OI AND
U.S. OFFICIALS ARE MAKINME THEF
FOR THE SAFE RETURN OF OUR
CITIZENS
>> Reporter: THE BUILDING THATNA
THE ACAN
SURVIVORS ARE BEING TRTHHOSPITI.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT THEY AREREL
.
THEY SAY THEY ARE EVENELEASING
PHOTOGRAPHS OF SOME OF
USE
ANTHVIDUALA 24-YEAR-OLD O WAS DN
ARRESTED.
OFFICIALS SAY CAN D MEN
LAS NO
REPORTER JOS CNN'S SECURIT
E JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
WHAT IS THROGAME
EMBASSY, YOU HAVE THE ALSO, S IU
CALLED THE COUNTM, A HOS
AN EMECYITTEE, HAVE MAJO CIES SD
ALL OFN SI      GIEING TO
BEAR SOMETHING ENFORCEMENT TION,
ICFR T LEVERAGE THEI
INTELLIGENCE, THEIR MA
INATWOG WITH THEIR
CLOSE PARTNERS IMEXICO.
TOLD THEY CLOS
WHERE THESE VICTIMS ARE.I TSMEXN
IT IS NTT
THH WE GET
A C HERE
TCIDENT, INVESTIGATION
IS NOT OVER.
THE FBI STILOFFERING A
CAPTURES.ADING TO DENT IROE
>> DO YOU THINK THE U.S.
T EXTRADITION, GIVEN THAT E CRI
AGAINST
>> I SUSPECT THEST WILL BE
MADE, IT'SO BE SEEN IF S WILLTO
ON ITS FACE, THIS APPEARS TO
T THAT WL
UNDER THE O TREATY,
WHERE YOU HAVE THE ATTAC
ER THE KILLINGMUFA TREATMENTY,
IT WASN'T JUST AMERICANS WHOBEEN
RE THIATTACK.
OFE, THERE WAS A
22-YEAR-OLD GI, A MEXICAN
TO PICK UP
HER CHILD WHO WASO CAU THIS CAR
HAITIAN NATIONALS,Y ENDEUPATTACG
O AMERICANS,
INJURI THE AND-OLD MEXICAN
JAKE, MEXICAN OFFICIALS
MAUCK
MA PROSETH IUN ENSURING
THAT J IS SERVEDW  DONWILL
CO>> JOSH MPK S THND MOS
N FOR MEDICAL ISM , PATIENTS WI
I                              .
AMERICANS CAN SAVE BEN
AND  COMMON MEDICA
PROC COURSE THEY
ARE TAKING RISKS, E THE
ARE DESIGNED TO DRAW ARI
ACROSS THE BIFALR MEDICACA
THAT.
>>, JAKE.
E VERY FIRSTHI PHARMACOR CLININ
TILTH  TORDER.CAY, THE
COTR YOU FTS SERVICES,
ICALLY DONE INONTROL
LA HAVPITALS
REQUIRE MORE CARE TREATMENT.
BUT THERE IS ONE TOWN INULAR IN
PHARMACIES, THEY COULDSTLLINUGY
CLINICS THATG
SEESNOW, THEY ARPEND
THE WINTEROUN WARMER
IMW THEY ARE GOINGTHEIS WITHEX
DRUGS THAT ARENDE CAN
S ABOUTHN AND OUE ROUS?>> THEY .
R T, T ATTACKS
CARTELS. ONE WE SAW ARE RVEDR C
THIS IS
TO THE GCARTEL, SOIT IS A
VERY VIOLENT CRIMINAL ORGANIZATT
ANCAER, AS
A ARE DURING
TH
IMINAL
ORGANIZAWANT TO GET
THAT'S WHY IT STDEITY,S AL